et laissez-moi vous présenter mes
invités de ce soir guillaume tranchant
ouvrage moi c'est grâce au web il
s'appelle or elle en fait pour marc
absire ici comme un exercice de maths
m6 était mort dans la même cité morts
sur l'île de batz grâce mais leur a pas
mal à mende avec un seul traque un seul
bras que ces jeunes gars tu rêves de but
de parfum et depuis vous avez pas fini
un seul morceau
non mais ça prend du temps de faire un
bon morceau cinq ans alors elle ne peut
pas aller plus vite que la musique avec
d'autres foutent de ma gueule grain je
vous ai fait cette maquette en cinq ans
et sur vos façons pour demain mais vous
n'êtes pas capable de faire bosser les
mecs mais si on est capable maintenant
tu es sa cape ann non mais sinon mais
sinon non si je dis que six mois wells
est mort c'est impossible on a du boulot
il ya zéro chance consorts
ah bon
je vous donnais un seul et unique
conseil les mecs sept meilleurs
abandonné je serais pas un peu [ __ ] rouler
en france et plus tard zones érogènes
tueur mais donne personne ne touche
jamais encore en deçà des khmers rouges
est vitale et m'a fait supporter un
accouchement elle supporte pas une vanne
à nos histoires morte avant d'avoir
démarré other laissez-passer popote
jamais rappelée au top j'ai lâché aux
fortes que j'ai claqué [ __ ] j'ai des
jeux de merde d'août a cru qu'on allait
percer dans le rap longa mais on n'a
rien de spécial mon pote on n'a rien ok
depuis on attend
non
je suis là on
comment j'ai faim commencée loin
tu peux te connais toi qui dans l
illusion qu à la place de trenet qui
retombe au studio stoppait j'avais même
pas qu'il y ait des buissons
à demain
rien ne bouge